je vais vous montrer
une magnifique mâchoire inférieure
d'un cousin fossile des éléphants
qui a été trouvé à tavers près de
Beaugency et qui a plus de 20 millions
d'années
après restauration cette pièce sera
exposée au Muséum d'Orléans au sein de
la collection paléontologie aux côtés de
ce calcaire
les Orléans ont puisé dans le sous-sol
on
montait créer des carrières ouverts des
carrières pour creuser des caves dans un
signe d'habitation et construire avec
ses pierres les anciennes d'habitation
d'Orléans tout simplement et dans ces
calcaires on en trouve on trouve
énormément de fossiles non loin de là
serait-il marin datant de 180 millions
d'années continuent à soulever des
interrogations
depuis la restauration effectivement de
ce spécimen on a vu apparaître ces
traces noires et on se questionne sur ce
que ça pourrait être il y a la
possibilité que ce soit des traces de
matière organique aux mobs les
scientifiques établissent le cycle de
l'évolution des espèces la collection
d'insectes avec plus de 300 000
spécimens est une véritable manne les
collections sciences naturelles leur
intérêts augmentent avec le nombre de
spécimens qu'on a et c'est pas des
copies en fait c'est pas des copies
qu'on pourrait
ne pas conserver ou qu'on moins
d'intérêt c'est vraiment intéressant
parce que c'est ce qui nous permet
d'avoir de représenter le plus
correctement possible la diversité qu'il
y a au sein d'une espèce
sensibiliser le grand public aux enjeux
environnementaux c'est l'une des
missions que c'est assigné le MOB et ça
passe par une foule d'animation grand
public tout au long de l'année avec un
cycle de conférence qui débute le 31
janvier
chercheur ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils vont pouvoir nous expliquer on a
on s'est attaché à les choisir aussi de
manière à ce qu'il soit très pédagogue
et donc ils vont pouvoir nous expliquer
comment fonctionne le vivant
il y a mille choses à voir et à faire
aux mobs comme par exemple admirer ce
lion de la classe une espèce disparue
d'Afrique du Nord il Mémoriam